I've been doing this podcast and I've
been having a blast doing it and then I
did an episode with you of the podcast
that had a tremendous response people
really loved it so I said hey Dana would
you like to do some mini episodes of
podcasts with me it's basically just me
setting him up and him doing routines
and it's been an absolute joy and those
would be I think there's six podcasts
were dropped this summer
yeah I want to make sure I got the
mention of those right no it was at Kona
was a very generous and he just kind of
set me up we in the end of the day we
have a very similar sense of humor it's
very acid II redundant phrases that make
our brains happy yeah very silly very
silly yeah or abstract yeah I prefer
sometimes stupid I prefer stupid we're
not really Swift on the uptake we're
slow example but that was really really
fun it's out in August we got all six
episodes of DJI with dana drop on
stitcher premium july first get a free
month with code Conan and starting
August of willya so download air weekly
at Apple podcast Spotify where we get
your podcast it's just a fun thing that
I want people to listen to yeah if
you're especially if you're into comedy
or just it it's just a joy I just laugh
I spend the whole time I think if this
guy we yeah you do this thing that I
absolutely love which is Johnny Carson
getting pulled over right Johnny Carson
in his car in the 70s getting pulled
over he's had way too much to drink and
he tells the officer what the name of
the dream the name of the drink and
where he had the drink all these
seventies references yeah he references
and it just I don't know it made me I
was crying
oh sorry officer I didn't know I was
swerving I had to strawberry boom booms
at the slippery Tim's
[Laughter]
do those all day we were doing those all
day that was that's a pretty straight
one they get weirder
I really enjoy mister Frosty's at the
ducky hut so it's almost like he's not
even drinking alcohol that they're just
fine a festive names you know it's
mostly having eight thousand grams of
sugar it's just big fruity drinks sorry
officer I had to slippery monkeys at the
hook and crow that was the key to it so
this is what made us happy so you're
gonna download the podcast yeah here
[Music]